et non non non non c'est ma bague et
c'est ma blague il
n'empêche pas le pain
pas possible elliott donc ça non plus
et le manioc
[Musique]
on a une petite surprise pour
jean a fait déjouer je suis un peu comme
ça vous allez jouer agen n'en
écoute on a fait un truc avec arvest
après-midi un truc
complètement fou répété non plus mais en
fait c'est un truc exclusif mais c'est
vraiment hard et moi qui l'avons fait au
ton style et on a la classe exemple là
et c'est un vrai truc sérigraphié
merci j'ai pas méritée on commence une
visite censée échapper
de vente ou pas derrière que devant
vas-y
a
averti peu trop de
[Musique]
voiliers
vont pouvoir rembourser les machines
physiques ont
compris que
personne ne me sur la catastrophe que
représente sa le portable à personne de
sexe et la guerre contre la courtoisie
la délicatesse le détour la conversation
personne et je suis d'avis que je suis
pas là en train de dire que je juge j'en
suis un esclave comme du crack ma
compagne me dit mais arrête de critiquer
tous les gens qui filment leurs
portables leurs plats tu ne connais rien
c'est peut-être une influence euse mots
que je hais c'est un mot que je vais
influence us